snatched away from my old life so quick  I got that down I could see why people  would end up committing suicide I went  to Beijing nineteen years old young  Lewis Smith got the first ever Olympic  medal there the first medal pgb in a  hundred years  I come home and if it was so different  there was a lot to digest literally  overnight my kids went outside my house  their people recognized my name  I think people can look  on successful people and think  everything in their life is perfect  it could be further away from the truth  and there's a lot more to just being  happy and successful that's not what  whether that's talking to people around  you have you got people you can trust I  think men who tried to be proud and  almost at a point they tried to be in  denial anything was wrong it was as much  as boy was over I mean your brain is  like any other party buddy it's all  about trying to prevent injury  [Applause]